THE ASSEMBLY IS NOW IN SESSION.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM. THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS AND THE CLERK WILL CALL
THE ROLL.
ACOSTA AGUIAR-CURRY.
ALLEN.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BONTA.
BROUGH.
BURKE
CABALLERO CALDERON CARILLO
SERVAN TE'S CHAU CHAVEZ
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY
COOPER. CUNNINGHAM DALLY.
DALY.
EGGMAN EN.
FLORA FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA.
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
GRAY.
GRACE EN
HARPER.
HOLDEN IRWIN JONES SAWYER. KALRA
CAM LAGER DOES.
KILEY LACKEY LEVINE LIMON.
LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES
MCCARTY. MEDINA MELENDEZ.
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE. O'DONNELL PATTERSON
QUIRK
QUIRK SILVA. REYES RODRIGUEZ
RUBIO
SOLACE
SANTIAGO STEINORTH.
STONE.
THURMOND.
TING.
VOEPEL.
WALDRON.
WELL WOULD.
MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER.
WILL BE OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN REVEREND BOB OSHITA.
REVEREND.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
APRIL.
IS A THOUGHTFUL MONTH FOR MY
FAMILY.
I WILL NEVER FORGET THE APRIL
AFTERNOON IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE.
THAT I RECEIVED THE CALL THAT I
HAD LOST MY DAD.
AND I WILL NEVER FORGET THE
EARLY MORNING IN APRIL OF TWO
THOUSAND FIVE.
WHEN MY MOM TOOK HER LAST
BREATH.
NOT LONG AFTER MY MOTHER DIED. A
FRIEND WHO HAD RECENTLY LOST HIS
BROTHER SAID TO ME.
IT HASN'T BEEN AN EASY YEAR HAS
IT.
MY RESPONSE WAS.
I FOUND THE OLDER I BECOME.
THERE ARE NO EASY YEARS.
I. I THINK THE LAST EASY YEAR I
CAN REMEMBER WAS WHEN I WAS NINE
OR TEN YEARS OLD.
ARE SUBDUED LAUGHTER OF
AGREEMENT WAS FOLLOWED BY A
THOUGHTFUL SILENCE.
A SILENCE DURING WHICH I THINK
WE BOTH TRIED TO REACH BACK INTO
OUR MEMORIES TO SEE. IF WE COULD
REMEMBER JUST A MOMENT OF THAT
SIMPLE INNOCENCE.
BUT IN KNOWING WE'LL LOS.
OUR WISDOM EYES OPEN.
SEE WHAT IS REALLY OF VALUE AND
LIVING LIFE.
WIENER WISDOM EYES OPEN. WE WILL
CHERISH OUR DAYS OF GOOD HEALTH.
AND TREASURE EVERY OPPORTUNITY.
HOLD CLOSE TO PEOPLE WHOSE LIVES
GIVE MEANING TO OUR OWN.
NUMBER ONE NEED. WITH GRATITUDE
AND KINDNESS BEYOND.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING. AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAYES AS HE LEADS US IN
THE PLEDGE MISTER MAYES.
READY BEGIN I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
ISRAEL.
THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL. ASSEMBLY CHAMBER
SACRAMENTO THURSDAY APRIL
TWELFTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE SEMI
MAD AT NINE A. M. ON A LARK
FRIEDMAN IS IS A SPEAKER PRO TEM
OF THE ASSEMBLY PRESIDING
CHEAPER  DOES YOUR.
CALDERON MOVES AND MISS BAKER
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS THERE
ARE NONE INTRODUCTION REFERENCE
OF BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
WOULD YOU MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR THE
DAY.
FOR LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER VINCE FONG.
AND FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FREDDIE RODRIGUEZ
MEMBERS WE ARE AT PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS.
MISTER. CALLED AROUND.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ONE EIGHTEEN NAY
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
MCCARTY TO HAVE GUESTS AND
PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE FLOOR TODAY
HIS GUESTS WILL BE SEATED AS
DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE
FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE. AND ALLOW
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS LACKEY CARILLO
FRIEDMAN AND CALM LAGER DOVE AND
SANTEE IAGO TO SPEAK ON
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER. PURSUANT TO ASSEMBLY
RULE NINETY SIX I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO RE REFER
THE FOLLOWING BILLS TO
COMMITTEE.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE
CARILLO FROM THE COUNT ABILITY
ADMINISTRATIVE REVIEW COMMITTEE
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AB THIRTY THIRTY COUNTY AT ALL
FROM THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT
COMMITTEE TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AN SP FOUR FIFTY TWO
GLAZER. FROM THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE NINETY SIX. ON THE
FOLLOWING NON FISCAL BILLS. AB
EIGHTEEN OR TO SOLACE WITHDRAW
FROM THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE IN ORDER THE BILL TO
SECOND READING. AND AB THIRTY
SIXTY SEVEN SHALL WITHDRAW FROM
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
RE REFER THE BILL TO THE PRIVACY
AND CONSUMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE REMOVE ITEM ONCE
ANY FIVE ACR TO A FIVE WALDRON
FROM THE CONSENT CAL.
CLERK WILL NOTE.
IT WAS COUPLE OF QUICK
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
TODAY IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC
LEVINE BIRTHDAY HAPPY BIRTHDAY
MISTER LIVING.
AND SUNDAY.
THIS PAST SUNDAY WAS.
THIS UPCOMING SON.
THIS PAST SUNDAY.
WAS DR PHIL JAN'S BIRTHDAY WE
MISSED IT.
MEMBERS WE HAVE GUESTS WITH US
IN THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBER TODAY.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO MISTER STONE
MEMBERS.
MISTER STONE YOU HAVE GUESTS
WITH US TODAY I DO THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. MEMBERS BUT WE.
YEARS AGO I CAME UP TO THIS
CAPITAL WITH MY DID FOR MY
DAUGHTER AND HER FOURTH GRADE
CLASS OUR TEACHER WAS LINDA MIL
HAS ARE FROM BROOK NO. I'D LIKE
TO INTRODUCE YOU TO THIS BILL
HAZARDS CURRENTS FOURTH GRADE
CLASS FROM BROOK NO.
AND SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
GO EAGLES UP IN.
THE GALLERY TO THE NORTH
.
MEMBERS I BELIEVE.
MR MCCARTY.
HAS A VIP ON THE FLOOR WITH US
TODAY
STIR MCCARTY OR RECOGNIZE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AS WE
KNOW TODAY IS THE TWENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY OF TAKE YOUR
DAUGHTER TO TAKE YOUR DAUGHTER
AND YOUR SON TO WORK DAY. AND
THAT CERTAINLY OUR OUR.
INTENTION TO INSPIRE OUR OUR
SONS AND DAUGHTERS TO DO GREAT
THINGS IN THIS WORLD AND WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE ONE OF MY DAUGHTERS
VICTORIA. MCCARTY AND LIKE TO
WELCOME HER HERE TO THE ASSEMBLY
FLOOR. AND.
.
HAPPY TAKE YOUR DAUGHTER AND SON
TO WORK DAY THANK YOU
MEMBERS WHERE BUSINESS ON THE
DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING.
THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE SIXTY
NINE TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
THEM IMMENSELY EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY ONE OF FOUR THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY THREE WITH MOMENTS
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SIX OF THE
MOMENTS TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS AS UNABLE TWENTY
ONE EIGHTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS
TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN WITH THE
MOMENT SEVENTEEN FORTY FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S.
TWENTY ONE FORTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY ONE NINETY
WITH AMENDMENTS TWENTY NAY
THROUGH WITH AMENDMENTS. TWENTY
SIX FORTY THREE WITH MOMENTS
THIRTY THIRTY TWO WITH THE
MEMONS TWENTY TWENTY FIVE THIRTY
TWO TWENTY FOUR.
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
TWO ONE FOURTH AMENDMENT'S.
AS UNABLE TO NINETEEN NINETY SIX
AT THE MOMENT EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN NINETEEN FIFTY THREE
TWENTY FIFTY SEVEN TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY FIVE. TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
FOUR TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY EIGHT FIFTY NINE.
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY FIVE NINETEEN
FORTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY EIGHTY SIX TWENTY NINETY
FIVE.
TWENTY ONE OH NINE TWENTY ONE
NINETY TWO. POINT THREE L.
WANTING A THREE FIFTY SEVEN
TWENTY THREE NINETY ONE. TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
FORTY NINE TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR EIGHTY THREE.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY SIX TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY ONE TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY NINE.
TWENTY FIVE FORTY ONE TWENTY
FIVE NINETY TWO. TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWENTY SIX SIXTY ONE
TWENTY SIX SEVENTY NINE. TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY EIGHT TWENTY NINE THIRTY
EIGHT TWENTY NINE FORTY FOUR
TWENTY NINE FORTY NINE. THIRTY
FOURTEEN. THIRTY THIRTY SIX
THIRTY FORTY SEVEN THIRTY
SEVENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVENTY
EIGHT THIRTY ONE TWELVE THIRTY
ONE TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE THIRTY
THREE. THIRTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
THIRTY TO THIRTY ONE.
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY FIVE WHAT
THE MOMENT SEVENTEEN EIGHTY SIX
OF THE MOMENTS TWENTY ONE SIXTY
SIX WITH AMENDMENTS. TWENTY TO
FORTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS WAY
SEVEN SEVENTY ONE A COMMITMENTS
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS RAIN FOR FORTY SEVEN
WITH AMENDMENTS. TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS TO
A SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN WITH THE
MOMENTS TWENTY EIGHT SIXTEEN AT
THE MOMENTS WHEN I THIRTY FOURTH
AMENDMENT'S. TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS TWENTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHT WITH AMENDMENTS THIRTY
EIGHTY ONE OF THE MOMENTS.
TWENTY FOUR SIXTEEN WITH
AMENDMENTS POINT SIXTY ONE ABOUT
BUT THE MOMENTS TWENTY THREE
SIXTY THREE AT THE MOMENTS
TWENTY SEVEN FORTY SEVEN AT THE
MOMENT.
THIRTY ONE FORTY TWO WITH THE
MEMONS TWENTY EIGHTY NINE WITH
AMENDMENTS MADE TO FIFTY FIVE AT
THE MOMENT. TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT AMENDMENTS MAYPORT SIXTY
THREE AT THE MOMENT MADE BY
NINETY SIX
BUT THE MOMENTS TWENTY SIX
EIGHTY SEVEN WITH THE MEMBERS
TWENTY FIVE CITY WITH
AMENDMENTS.
TWENTY ONE SEVEN EIGHTS YOU AND
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY EIGHT WITH
AMENDMENTS
.
ALL BILLS HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL GAS
WITH US IN THE CHAMBER TODAY.
MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GAS.
MEMBERS.
SHE GARCIA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES RIGHT
ABOVE WHERE I'M STANDING.
TWO OF OUR FINEST ELECTED
OFFICIALS THAT REPRESENT THE
COACHELLA VALLEY ARE HERE
VISITING WITH US TODAY.
FIRST I'D LIKE TO INTRODUCE DAN
HENRY. WHO WAS ELECTED TO THE
CITY COUNCIL COULD PEOPLE CITY
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AND WAS
ELECTED MAYOR IN TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN?
PRIOR TO SERVING ON THE CITY
COUNCIL. HE SERVED THIRTY THREE
YEARS IN PUBLIC SAFETY AND A
HANDFUL OF THEM WERE AS THE
CHIEF OF POLICE FOR THE CITY OF
THE PEOPLE CITY.
WITH HIM TODAY IS ALSO THE MAYOR
PRO TEM.
MAYOR PRO TEM GREAT PEDIS
WHO HAS SERVED FOR MORE THAN TWO
DECADES IN THE CITY IN THE CITY
OF WITH NO CITY. AND IS THE
LONGEST SERVING COUNCILMEMBER
FOR THE COACHELLA VALLEY.
AND.
HE IS THE FIRST OPENLY ELECT GAY
ELECTED OFFICIALS THE COACHELLA
VALLEY SOMETHING THAT WE'RE VERY
PROUD OF. I NOT GOT TO INTRODUCE
HIM A CITY THAT RECENTLY WAS
RECOGNIZED AS THE ONE HUNDRED
PERCENT RATING FOR HUMAN RIGHTS
CAMPAIGN. FOR DIVERSITY PLEASE
HELP ME WELCOME THESE GREAT
LEADERS FROM THE COACHELLA
VALLEY
.
AND MS BURKE.
MS BURKE HAS A VIP ON THE FLOOR
TODAY.
READY FOR HER INTRODUCTION.
MS BURKE. YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
I GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ARE MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS IS MY DAUGHTER
ISABELLA BACK FOR HER THIRD YEAR
OF BRINGING BRING YOUR DAUGHTER
TO WORK DAY WES A HIGH.
I
.
MEMBERS RETURNING TO BUSINESS ON
THE DAILY FILE.
WE ARE AT CONCURRENCE.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINETY FOUR.
A. B. TWELVE NINETY TWO AND THE
CORPORATE RATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER PATTERSON AND
ACTUALLY TO ENERGY UTILITY
SERVICE SAYS.
MISTER PATTERSON EMAIL. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
BUT AB TWELVE NINETY TWO IS BACK
FOR CONCURRENCE FROM THE SENATE.
IN ONGOING DISCUSSIONS AT THE
SEAT UP THE CPUC STAKEHOLDERS
AGREE THAT MORE ACCURATE DATA
CALCULATION OF THE BASELINE
CONSUMPTION OF ELECTRICITY WOULD
BE ACHIEVED BY. SEPARATELY
CONSIDERING RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS WHO UTILIZE SOLAR OR
OTHER TYPES OF DISTRIBUTED
GENERATION IN ORDER TO ACHIEVE A
FAIRER. AND MORE ACCURATE
BASELINE CALCULATION.
THE BILL REQUIRES THE CPUC TO
ACCOUNT FOR THE DIFFERENCES IN
THESE CUSTOMERS DURING THEIR
GENERAL RATE CASE PROCEEDINGS.
ADDRESSING HIGH RATES IS
IMPORTANT ACROSS THE STATE.
OF THE LEGISLATURE HAS DEEMED
THAT A PRIORITY IN PASSING
SEVERAL BILLS. OF THE AMENDMENTS
OVER IN THE SENATE WERE MINOR
AND I GIVE OTHER PEOPLE SEE SOME
ADDITIONAL FLEXIBILITY AND
IMPLEMENTATION THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND ZERO NO VOTES. I
REQUEST WE REQUEST YOUR
CONCURRENCE.
THEY MISS PATTERSON SCENE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
THE CLERK LOVE FOR THE ROLE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE IS OUT OF VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE YOUR ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE
SIXTY EIGHT NOSE. THE SENATE
AMENDMENTS
ARE CONCURRENT AND.
ON.
RECONSIDERATION ITEMS NINETY
FIVE THROUGH NINETY NINE WILL BE
CONTINUED.
S. BRINGS US TO THE THIRD
READING FILE.
FILE ITEM ONE HUNDRED PASS A
RETAIN.
FILE ITEM.
ONE OF ONE IS AB TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE THE CLERK WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
NINE BY SOME THE MEMBER EDUARDO
GARCIA AND OTHERS ACTUALLY THE
STATE MEMORIALS.
MR GARCIA YOU MAY OPEN. MISTER
SPEAKER AND COLLEAGUES PROUD TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR THIRTY
NINE.
ON MAY TWENTY SEVENTH TWO
THOUSAND ONE THE AM VETS POST
SIXTY SIX ERECTED A MONUMENT AT
THE DESERT MEMORIAL PARK IN
CATHEDRAL CITY. CALIFORNIA IN
ORDER TO HONOR LGBT VETERANS
MAKING THEM MORE AT THE FIRST OF
ITS KIND IN THE UNITED STATES.
SUCH A MOMENTOUS DEDICATION DID
NOT GO UNNOTICED IN FACT. THERE
WERE A HANDFUL OF PRESIDENTS
WHO WROTE BACK WITH SPECIAL
LETTERS PRAISING THIS MEMORIAL.
AND THE COMMUNITY PRESIDENT'S
LIKE GERALD FORD BILL CLINTON
GEORGE BUSH.
AND PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
IT ALSO DIDN'T GO UNNOTICED
BY SEVERAL OF OUR GOVERNOR'S.
GOVERNOR DAVIS SCHWARZENEGGER
AND OUR CURRENT GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN.
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY NINE WOULD MAKE
CALIFORNIA THE FIRST STATE IN
THE UNION TO HAVE AN OFFICIAL
STATE. LGBT VETERANS MEMORIAL.
CALIFORNIA MUST HONOR ALL THE
BRAVE MEN AND WOMEN WHO HAVE
SERVED IN OUR NATION'S ARMED
FORCES THIS MEMORIAL IS A
TESTAMENT TO OUR HONOR AND THE
CONTRIBUTIONS THE LGBT COMMUNITY
HAS MADE. TO SECURITY OF THE
UNITED STATES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS GARCIA.
SAYING.
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CAR CLUB THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF THOSE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE AND
TALLY THE VOTE I SIXTY SEVEN NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
WHILE I DON'T WANT TO PASS
RETAIN.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED YET THEY YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'D JUST LIKE TO ASK THE
MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR I KNOW
WE'RE BUSY WAS LOT THINGS GOING
ON WERE ALL WORKING ON THINGS.
UP AWHILE MEMBERS ARE PRESENTING
THEIR BILLS IS GETTING EXTREMELY
LOUD AND I'D LIKE THAT WE SAID
WE WE GIVE DEFERENCE AND RESPECT
TO THE MEMBERS ARE PRESENTING
THEIR BILLS WE KEEP OUR
CONVERSATIONS.
I TO A MINIMUM.
THANK YOU FOR THAT REMINDER MUCH
CALDERON.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE ALL THREE.
THIS IS AB TWENTY SEVEN NINETY
ONE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
NINETY ONE BY SOME THE MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AND OTHERS AND
ACTUALLY TO ANIMALS.
MISTER MURATSUCHI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
TODAY I AM ASKING YOU TO TAKE
THE MOST IMPORTANT VOTE OF OUR
POLITICAL CAREERS HERE.
SAVE OUR KITTENS AND PUPPIES.
THIS BILL WILL ALLOW KITTENS AND
PUPPIES.
HOMELESS IMPOUNDED.
TO BE ELIGIBLE FOR IMMEDIATE
RELEASE.
TO AN ANIMAL RESCUE OUR ADOPTION
ORGANIZATION.
RATHER THAN BE EUTHANIZED.
THIS BILL IS SPONSORED BY THE
SPCA.
WHAT'S SO.
OUR COUNTRY THAT DEMOCRATS
REPUBLICANS WE CAN UNITE TO SAVE
OUR KITTENS AND PUPPIES I ASK
VERY AYE ABOUT.
DOCUMENTS URATSUCHI SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
HOW COULD THERE BE?
CLARK WELL HEY'RE ALL. ON
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLE I SEVENTY.
NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE OF FOUR THROUGH
ONE AWAY PASS RETAIN.
THAT BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE OH NINE.
AB NINETEEN NINETY THREE BY
MISTER GIPSON THE CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN NINETY
THREE BY SOME REMEMBER GET
SENATE ACTUALLY THE SECONDHAND
GOODS.
MISTER GIPSON. GOOD MORNING
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
NINETY THREE WHICH SEEKS TO
GREAT EVENING WELL EVEN THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR SECONDHAND
DEALERS IN THERE. ARENA OF
RESELLING GOODS FOR EXAMPLE WHEN
INDIVIDUAL WALKS INTO A PAWNSHOP
JURY STORE AND ANY BUSINESS THEY
BUY ITEMS FROM A PRIVATE CITIZEN
THEY MUST HOLD THE ITEMS. FOR
THIRTY DAYS BEFORE PUTTING THEM
UP FOR SALE MEANWHILE ONLINE
THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF WEB SITES
LIKE CRAIGSLIST FACEBOOK WHERE
YOU CAN EASILY BUY SECONDHAND
GOODS THAT SAME DAY. A. B.
NINETEEN NINETY THREE SIMPLY
SEEKS TO CREATE AN EVEN PLAYING
FIELD FOR SECONDHAND ON DEALERS
BY REDUCING THIRTY DAYS HOLE TO
ITEMS.
TO A PRIVATE CITIZENS TO FIVE
DAYS I RESPECTFULLY ASK BUT I
VOTE ON ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
NINETY THREE.
THAT WAS GIPSON SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THIS ITEM.
CLERK LIBERAL.
TO DECIDE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
AYE SIXTY TWO KNOWS ONE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE TEN OF ONE ELEVEN
PASS RETAIN. WERE FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE TWELVE.
AB NINETEEN EIGHTY.
CORKERY.
SOME PEOPLE NINETEEN EIGHTY BY
SOME A MEMBER QUIRK AND ACTUALLY
INTO STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
DOCTOR QUIRK EMAIL WHEN.
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AB
NINETEEN EIGHTY EXTENDS THE
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS.
FOR COMMENCING SEVERAL
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS FOR BOB
GRAHAM PETROLEUM STORAGE ACT.
VIOLATIONS FROM ONE YEAR TO
FIVE YEARS.
A ONE YEAR STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS IS INSUFFICIENT.
BECAUSE IT TYPICALLY TAKES A
YEAR OR MORE TO COMPLETE
INVESTIGATIONS INVOLVING ABOVE
GROUND STORAGE TANKS.
THESE ARE COMPLEX INVESTIGATIONS
THAT OFTEN INVOLVE VIOLATIONS OF
MULTIPLE ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS.
SPILLS FROM PETROLEUM TANKS CAN
LEAD TO HOST PROBLEMS.
CONTAMINATED SOIL AND DRINKING
WATER. INCREASED FIRE RISK.
THIS ACT WAS ENACTED NINETEEN
NINETY AS A DIRECT RESPONSE.
TO THE SPELL OF MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND GALLONS OF
PETROLEUM FROM ABOVE GROUND
PETROLEUM TANKS INTO SENSITIVE
MARSHES.
IN THE BAY DELTA ESTUARY.
AT FIVE YEARS THE STATUE OF
LIMITATIONS WOULD BE CONSISTENT.
WITH THE OTHER LAWS UNDER THE.
UNIFIED PROGRAM WHICH ENFORCES
HAZARDOUS MATERIAL LOSS.
THIS PARITY.
WOULD ENABLE.
PROSECUTORS TO EFFECTIVELY
ENFORCE THESE IMPORTANT LAWS.
IN THE SAME MANNER THEY
CURRENTLY IN FORCE OTHER AREAS
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW.
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU ARRIVE OUT.
THE DUCT WORK SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE.
CLICK LIBERAL. VOTERS OUT OF
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
ALL MEMBERS VOTED AS OUR VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLLTIDE ABOUT I SUCCEED
YOU KNOW ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN
HOUSE RETAIN.
FILE ITEM ONE FOURTEEN. AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE BY SOME A MEMBER
KALRA ACTUALLY PRIVILEGE.
MISTER KALRA YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE WOULD
ESTABLISH AN EVIDENTIARY
PRIVILEGE BY HIM AT THE
DISCLOSURE OF CONFIDENTIAL
COMMUNICATIONS.
MAYBE TEN EMPLOYEE IN THEIR
UNION REPRESENTATIVE.
PRIVILEGE AND EXCLUSIONARY RULE
OF EVIDENCE THAT PROTECT CERTAIN
CLASS OF COMMUNICATIONS FROM
DISCLOSURE TWO OPPOSING PARTIES
FROM ENTRY INTO EVIDENCE A LEGAL
PROCEEDINGS.
THE RATIONALE IS THAT ALTHOUGH
CERTAIN INFORMATION MAY BE
RELEVANT IT IS NONETHELESS
EXCLUDED BECAUSE OF OVERRIDING
SOCIAL INTERESTS.
AT A TIME WHEN THE MEAT TO
MOVEMENT IS EMPOWERED WOMEN AND
OTHERS TO REPORT TO SPEAK OUT
ABOUT HARASSMENT THE WORKPLACE.
ADDITIONAL CONFIDENTIAL AB NEWS
REPORT THESE INCIDENCES ARE IN
GREATER NEED AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE WOULD ADD UNION AGENT
REPRESENT A WORKER. HAS
RECOGNIZED ACTUALLY EVIDENTLY
PRIVILEGE ALONG WITH ELEVEN
EXISTING TYPES COMMUNICATIONS
DEEMED PRIVILEGED BY ALLOWING
EVIDENTIARY PRIVILEGE BETWEEN
WORKERS AND YOU REPRESENTATIVES.
WE CAN HELP TO ENSURE THE SAFE
PRIVATE AND FULL DISCLOSURE OF
WORKPLACE CONCERNS AND NEEDS A
RESPECT TO UPSET THE ASPEN IDA.
NAMES KALRA SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK LOCAL ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTED OUT OF THE
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
AN ICE FORTY ONE KNOWS TWENTY.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTEEN. THROUGH
OR ONE TWENTY.
PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE ARE FILE ITEM OF ONE
TWENTY ONE THIS IS HR ONE OH ONE
FOR COREY.
HOUSE RESOLUTION ONE A ONE BY
SOME MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND OTHERS
RELATIVE TO SEXUAL SAW AWARENESS
MONTH AND DENIM DAY. MS FRIEDMAN
YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT HR ONE A ONE
THE DENIM DAY SEXUAL ASSAULT
AWARENESS MONTH RESOLUTION.
WE ALL RECOGNIZE DENIM DAY AS
THE ONE DAY EACH YEAR WE GET TO
BUST OUT OF OUR BLAZERS AND
TIES.
AND ROCK OUR FAVORITE PAIR OF
JEANS
BUT DEBT OF DAY REPRESENTS SO
MUCH MORE THAN SUPPORTING OUR
OFFICIAL STATE FABRIC WHILE ON
THE JOB.
IT'S ROOT CAUSES MUCH MORE
SERIOUS AND MUCH MORE TROUBLING.
TWENTY YEARS AGO THE ITALIAN
SUPREME COURT REVERSED THE
CONVICTION OF A MAN WHO RAPED AN
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD WOMAN.
THE COURT DETERMINED THAT THE
ATTACK MOST OF THE CONSENSUAL
BECAUSE THE WOMAN WAS WEARING
JEANS THAT WERE SO TIGHT THAT
THE ONLY WAY TO REMOVE THEM
WOULD BE WITH HER HELP.
RATHER THAN BELIEVE THAT HER
FORTY FIVE YEAR OLD DRIVING
INSTRUCTOR.
I TAKE HER TO AN ISOLATED ROAD
REMOVE HER FROM THE CAR WRESTLE
HER OUT OF HER JEANS AND RAPED
HER.
THE CHIEF JUSTICE EXCUSE THE
MAN'S BEHAVIOR BY STATING QUOTE.
BECAUSE THE VICTIM WERE VERY
VERY TIGHT JEANS SHE HAD TO HELP
HIM REMOVE THEM AND BY REMOVING
THE JEANS IT WAS NO LONGER RAPE.
BUT CONSENSUAL SEX.
RIGHTFULLY ENRAGED BY THE CORD
WOMEN OF THE ITALIAN PARLIAMENT
SHOWED UP FOR WORK WEARING JEANS
TO PROTEST THIS.
SERB RULING.
THE FACT THAT WE STILL HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN
THIS COUNTRY DEMONSTRATE FOR
THIS TYPE OF RESOLUTION IS
STILL.
SO IMPORTANT TWENTY YEARS LATER.
I RECENTLY RECEIVED A LETTER
FROM ONE OF MY CONSTITUENTS WHO
RECOUNTED HER EXPERIENCE OF
BEING SEXUALLY ASSAULTED.
SHE USED THOSE EXPERIENCE TO
FUEL HER OWN PASSION.
AND HER DESIRE TO HELP OTHER
PEOPLE SPEAK WITH THEIR OWN
VOICES.
SHE WROTE TO ME.
ONCE MY VOICE WAS FOUND I WANTED
EVERYONE TO HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO SEE.
AS LEADERS IN THE STATE WE ARE
IN A UNIQUE POSITION TO SPEAK
OUT FOR THOSE WHO CANNOT SPEAK
FOR THEMSELVES.
WE HAVE TO CONTINUE TO RAISE OUR
VOICES TO LIFT THE STIGMA THAT
SURROUNDS SEXUAL VIOLENCE.
SO THAT OTHERS CAN FEEL
COMFORTABLE ALSO RAISING THEIR
VOICES.
IT'S INCUMBENT ON ALL OF US MEN
AND WOMEN TO BRING ATTENTION TO
THIS VERY SERIOUS ISSUE BECAUSE
THIS IS NOT JUST A WOMEN'S
ISSUE.
SEXUAL VIOLENCE AFFECTS EVERY
CALIFORNIAN REGARDLESS OF GENDER
AGE RACE CLASS RELIGION OR
SEXUAL ORIENTATION.
ONE IN EVERY THREE WOMEN AND ONE
IN EVERY SIX MEN WILL EXPERIENCE
SOME FORM OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN
THEIR LIFETIME.
I WILL ALSO SAY THAT TO ARE MALE
ALLIES THAT BEING THAT ALL I WHO
RAISES YOUR VOICE.
WHO DOESN'T STAND IDLY BY WHEN
YOU SEE EXPRESSIONS OF?
OF.
WOMEN BEING ASSAULTED WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU HEAR MEN DEMEAN WOMEN.
DISREGARD WOMEN.
SPEAK UP IN THAT MOMENT BECAUSE
IT'S THOSE ATTITUDES THAT LEADS
TO THE FEELING THAT MEN CAN
TREAT WOMEN AS OBJECTS AND
ASSAULT THEM.
I'M VERY PROUD AUTHORED THIS
YEAR'S DENIM DAY RESOLUTION.
AND ASK THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS.
THEY CAME IS FRIEDMAN.
MISS MELINDA S. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
I AM PROUD TO STAND TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF HR ONE  ONE TO
DESIGNATE APRIL A SEXUAL ASSAULT
AWARENESS MONTH.
WE DON'T KNOW SOMEONE WHO HAS
SUFFERED THE TRAUMA OF SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
SOME OF US IN THIS ROOM MAYBE
VICTIMS.
AND IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
HEALS OVERNIGHT IT TAKES TIME IT
LEAVES A DEEP WOUND AN ONGOING
PAIN FOR THE VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
BUT I AM PROUD TO SAY THAT WE
HAVE INVESTED IN THE NECESSARY
TECHNOLOGY TO HELP LAW
ENFORCEMENT FIND THE CULPRITS OF
THESE CRIMES. AND HAVE PROVIDED
HEALTH AND COUNSELING SERVICES
FOR HER RESOURCES FOR THE
SURVIVORS.
MORE RECENTLY WE ENSURE THAT OUR
LEGISLATIVE STAFF HAVE
WHISTLEBLOWER PROTECTIONS TO
REPORT SEXUAL ASSAULT IN THIS
BUILDING.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO MORE
TO PROTECT THE INNOCENT AND TO
ROOT OUT THOSE WHO PREY UPON
THEM.
WINSTON CHURCHILL ONCE SAID WE
SHOWED DROP FROM THE HEART OF
SUFFERING ITSELF THE MEANS OF
INSPIRATION AND SURVIVAL. I
HEARD YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MELINDA'S MISS
RUBIO YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
GOOD MORNING MR PICKED SPEAKER
AND MEMBERS OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE CHAIR ON THE METHOD
VIOLENCE I STAND IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF HR ONE ONE.
AN ESTIMATED FIVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION CALIFORNIA WOMEN AND MEN
EXPERIENCE INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE EACH YEAR.
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE AN
ESTIMATED NINE HUNDRED AND FORTY
EIGHT THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS.
WHERE THE VICTIMS OF SOME FORM
OF SEXUAL VIOLENCE?
AND WHEN FACTORING THAT SOME
VICTIMS WERE ASSAULTED
REPEATEDLY DURING THAT YEAR BUT
TOTAL INCIDENTS OF SEXUAL
VIOLENCE IN THE STATE EXCEEDS
ONE POINT ONE MILLION.
A TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN REPORT
FOUND THAT THE TANGIBLE COST OF
SEXUAL VIOLENCE IN CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING MEDICAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH CARE PREVENTION
INVESTIGATION SANCTIONING
TREATMENT AND VICTIM SERVICES
TOTAL OVER AT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS.
H. ARE ONE ONE DESIGNATES THE
MONTHLY PRO TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN A SEXUAL ASSAULT
AWARENESS MONTH AND RECOGNIZES
APRIL TWENTY FIFTH. AS THEM DAY
IN CALIFORNIA.
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AND ENCOURAGE
YOU TO SUPPORT HR ONE ONE THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO MS RACE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE IN SUPPORT
OF HR ONE TWO ONE.
WHICH RECOGNIZES APRIL TWENTY
FIFTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AS
DENIM DAY IN CALIFORNIA AND
ENCOURAGES EVERYONE TO WEAR
JEANS ON THAT DAY TO HELP
COMMUNICATE.
THE MESSAGE THAT THERE'S NO
EXCUSE FOR AND NEVER IN
INVITATION TO COMMIT RAPE.
I THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GLENDALE.
FOR EMPHASIZING THE IMPORTANCE
OF INCREASING AWARENESS BECAUSE
IT IS OUR RESPONSIBILITY TO
SUPPORT ALL RAPE SURVIVORS BY
TREATING THEM WITH DIGNITY
COMPASSION AND RESPECT.
WE MUST RECOGNIZE A STRAIN THE
COURAGE.
CHALLENGES OF THE VICTIMS AND
SURVIVORS OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND THEIR FAMILIES AND FRIENDS
AS THEY STRUGGLE TO COPE WITH
THE REALITY OF SEXUAL ASSAULT.
THERE IS NEVER AN INVITATION FOR
RAPE.
WE CONDEMN THE ACTIONS OF THE
ITALIAN SUPREME COURT WHICH IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT OVERTURNED
THE CONVICTION OF THE RAPIST. AS
DESCRIBED BY MY COLLEAGUE.
JUST AS THE WOMEN IN THE
PARLIAMENT LAUNCHED INTO
IMMEDIATE ACTION A PROTESTED BY
WEARING JEANS TO WORK.
WE ALSO JOINED IN SOLIDARITY.
YESTERDAY BY WEARING JEANS.
BY DOING SO WE PROTEST AGAINST
THE MISCONCEPTIONS THAT SURROUND
SEXUAL ASSAULT.
AND HARMFUL ATTITUDES ABOUT RAPE
AND SEXUAL ASSAULT THAT ALLOW
THESE CRIMES TO PERSIST
AND ALLOW SURVIVORS TO BE RE
VICTIMIZED THROUGH VICTIM
BLAMING ATTITUDES AND
UNRESPONSIVE. GOVERNMENT
SYSTEMS.
WE MUST NOT ALLOW THIS CULTURE
TO EXIST AND INSTEAD WE MUST
CHALLENGE A SOCIETAL MYTHS AND
BEHAVIORS BUT BUT THAT
PERPETUATE RAPE.
AND TO ENGAGE COMMUNITIES IN A
COMMON GOAL OF ENDING SEXUAL
ASSAULT
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MS REYES.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
MISS FRIEDMAN YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH.
THANK YOU ALL JUST ADD THAT.
EACH AND EVERY DAY WE ALL NEED
TO.
CONSTANTLY CHALLENGING
REEVALUATE THE SOCIETAL NORMS
THAT LEAD TO.
FEELINGS THAT ABOUT WHO IS
POWERFUL AND WHO IS WEAK ABOUT
WHAT MASCULINITY MEANS WHAT
FAMILY MEANS AND WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE A MAN.
AND PUSHED BACK ON THE ATTITUDES
THAT. TELL YOUNG MEN SOMETIMES
THAT. IT THAT. BEING MASCULINE
MEANS TO CONQUER TO CONQUER
WOMEN.
AND THAT IF WOMEN DON'T.
CHAU DON'T ACQUIESCE TO THEM
THAT THEY ARE THERE TO BE
CONQUERED IN THOSE ATTITUDES
START VERY EARLY IN VERY YOUNG
AND WE ALL NEED TO PUSH BACK ON
THOSE. IMAGES THAT ARE SHOWN IN
OUR SOCIETY TO YOUNG PEOPLE AND
OLDER PEOPLE AND SAY NO THAT'S
NOT ACCEPTABLE AND THAT'S NOT
WHAT IT IS TO BE A MAN IN OUR
SOCIETY AND THAT'S NOT WHAT IT
IS TO BE A WOMAN.
ONLY BY CHANGING THEIR CULTURAL
WE EVER REALLY AND SEXUAL
ASSAULT AND WITH THAT I WOULD
ASK FOR CO AUTHORS AND THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MS FRIEDMAN THE
AUTHORS ASKING THAT THE FIRST
WILL BE OPEN FOR CO AUTHORS ON
THE RICH HOUSE RESOLUTION THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS
ON HR ONE ON ONE THIS.
CO AUTHORS.
CO AUTHORS ON HR ONE A ONE.
CLERK.
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE THERE ARE
SEVENTY THREE CO AUTHORS ADDED.
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THIS
HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY
NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION.
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE TWENTY TWO
THIS IS AB THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
NINE BY MISTER COOPER THE CLERK
WILL READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE EIGHTY
NINE BY SOME A MEMBER COOPER AND
ACTUALLY TO MINORS MISTER
COOPER.
BUT MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB
THIRTY ONE EIGHTY NINE ALLOWS A
MINOR WHO'S THE VICTIM OF
INTIMATE PARTNER VIOLENCE.
TO CONSENT TO MEDICAL TREATMENT
WITHOUT PARENTAL CONSENT.
MANY MINERS IN FEAR THEIR
PARENTS OR GUARDIANS FINDING OUT
ABOUT ABUSE MAY NOT SEEK
TREATMENT FOR ABUSE FROM A
PARTNER.
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE REPORTS
AVERAGE ABOUT FIVE REPORTS PER
WEEK IN THE EMERGENCY
DEPARTMENT.
SINCE TWENTY FOURTEEN WE'VE SEEN
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED CASES.
THIS BILL ELIMINATES ADDITIONAL
LAYER OF COMPLICATION FOR
VICTIMS OF INTIMATE PARTNER
VIOLENCE IN MAKES IT EASIER FOR
MINORS WHO'VE BEEN ABUSED TO
SEEK HELP.
THIS BILL RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. AND NO NO VOTES ARE
STEFFI ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THINGS COOPER MS BAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'D DO YOU HAVE A
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THANK YOU I
KNOW WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS
JUST AS A POINT OF CLARIFICATION
AND THAT IS TO UNDERSTAND MORE
CLEARLY THE CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER
WHICH A PARENT WILL BE NOTIFIED.
OF THE IT'S MEANT DOMESTIC.
PARDON THE INTIMATE PARTNER
ABUSE I KNOW THERE'S A
DEFINITION THAT YOUR BILL
REFERENCES IT'S IN ANOTHER CODE
SECTION.
AND THAT THE BILL INTRO ALSO
SUMMARIZES THAT IF THE PHYSICIAN
WELL FIRST I ASK THAT QUESTION.
IF YOU CAN CLARIFY PLEASE PLEASE
UNDER WHICH CIRCUMSTANCES
PARENTS WILL STILL BE NOTIFIED
THAT THEIR MINOR CHILD HAS
VISITED A DOCTOR ABOUT INTIMATE
PARTNER ABUSE.
THE BE NOTIFIED AFTER THE FACT
AS LONG AS THE PARENT IS NOT THE
ABUSER.
GOD I THINK YOU KNOW MY OWN TIME
IF I MAY. AND I APPRECIATE THAT
BECAUSE THE IT AND ACTUALLY AND
AS WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT I JUST
WANNA SO I MORE REALIZE THAT
THERE ARE STILL SOME QUESTIONS
THAT WE'VE HAD TOGETHER. TO
DETERMINE THAT THE PARENTS WILL
BE NOTIFIED NOT ONLY NOT JUST IF
IT'S SUSPECTED CHILD ABUSE.
THERE'S CHILD ABUSE WHICH HAS
DEFINITIONS AND THEN THERE'S THE
DEFINITION YOU HAVE IN YOUR BILL
OF INTIMATE PARTNER ABUSE AND
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT IT'S
CLEAR THAT IF.
A DAUGHTER OF A PARENT IS BEING
ABUSED BY. A MINOR DOMESTIC. OR
A MINOR PARTNER THAT SHE MAY
HAVE THAT THE PARENTS
STILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
FIND OUT SO THAT THEY CAN TAKE.
APPROPRIATE ACTION WITHOUT ALSO
REALIZING THAT IF THE MINOR WITH
THE MINERS CONSENT.
IF THE MINOR IS.
ABUSED AND FEELS THAT THE
PARENTS ARE GOING TO HAVE A
REACTION THAT WILL KEEP THE
MINOR FROM GOING TO THE DOCTOR
WE DON'T WANT THAT. BUT MY READ
OF YOUR BILL JUST THE TEXT OF
THE BILL IS THAT IT. ONLY ALLOWS
THE PARENTS TO BE NOTIFIED IF
THE PHYSICIAN SUSPECTS CHILD
ABUSE.
AND I THINK AS THE BILL GOES
OVER TO THE SENATE WHICH I HOPE
WILL DO TODAY WILL BE SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY IT'S GONNA BE
REALLY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE WE
GET CLEAR ON THAT. BECAUSE THEY
DO SEE A POTENTIAL INCONSISTENCY
IN THE LANGUAGE AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT.
PARENTAL NOTIFICATION IF THE
PARENTS IS NOT THE ABUSER.
I CAN STILL HAPPEN AND AND THE
PARENTS CAN STILL THEN TAKE
ACTION TO PROTECT THEIR CHILDREN
FROM THAT RELATIONSHIP. THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MS BAKER MS MELENDEZ
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
COLLEAGUES THIS IS BAD PUBLIC
POLICY.
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
AUTHOR WHO ENJOY WORKING WITH
AND I HAVE A GREAT RESPECT FOR
BECAUSE OF HIS CAREER IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THE AUTHOR STATEMENT SAYS THAT
THIS BILL WILL REMOVE THE
BARRIERS FOR MINERS WHO HAVE
BEEN ASSAULTED.
IT SHOULD FURTHER GO ON TO SAY
IT REMOVES THE PARENTS.
FROM THEIR RESPONSIBILITY WITH
THEIR CHILD.
IMAGINE IF YOU HAVE A CHILD
LET'S SAY THERE'S A CHILD A GIRL
YOUNG GIRL SHE'S THIRTEEN
FOURTEEN WHATEVER.
SHE HAS A BOYFRIEND.
AND THE PARENTS DON'T LIKE HIM.
AND THEY TOLD HER NOT TO SEE
HIM.
SHE DOES ANYWAY AS TEENAGERS DO.
AND THEN SHE'S ASSAULTED.
THEN SHE FEELS LIKE SHE CAN'T GO
TELL HER PARENTS
BECAUSE HE'S GOING TO GET MORE
TROUBLE.
BECAUSE SHE WASN'T SUPPOSED TO
SEE HIM ANYWAY AND OH BY THE WAY
OUR PARENTS DIDN'T LIKE HIM IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
SO WITH THAT THE POINT IN TIME
WHERE WE'RE GOING TO REMOVE THE
PARENTS FROM THE EQUATION REMOVE
THEM FROM THEIR CHILD'S LIFE AT
A TIME WHEN THAT CHILD IS GOING
TO NEED HER MOTHER OR FATHER AT
THE MOST.
THAT IS VERY THAT'S A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP IN THIS PROCESS
OF HEALING FOR A CHILD WHO HAS
BEEN ASSAULTED. THEY'RE YOUNG
THEY ARE VULNERABLE THEY'RE NOT
MATURE ENOUGH TO UNDERSTAND ALL
OF THE THOUGHTS THEY'RE HAVING A
WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO THEM AND
THE LAST THING I THINK WE WANT
TO DO. IS TO TELL THEM.
GO TO STRANGERS IN THE MEDICAL
PROFESSION AND HAVE THEM HELP
YOU AND LATER ON AFTER THE FACT.
THEN YOU CAN YOU MAY TELL THE
PARENTS.
EVERY GOING TO ALLOW THE PARENTS
TO BE NOTIFIED.
WHY DOES IT HAVE TO BE AFTER THE
FACT?
WHY WOULDN'T IT BE BEFORE WHY
ARE WE REMOVING PARENTS?
FROM THEIR CHILD'S LIVES.
THIS IS UNCONSCIONABLE AND I
UNDERSTAND I'M SURE THAT THAT
THE MOTIVE IS GENUINE AND
SINCERE. BUT I THINK THIS IS BAD
PUBLIC POLICY AND I THINK WE
OUGHT NOT BE INTERVENING AND
SEPARATING PARENTS FROM THEIR
CHILDREN AT A TIME WHEN THAT
CHILD PROBABLY NEEDS THEIR
PARENTS THE MOST THEY'VE. EVER
IN THEIR LIVES PLEASE VOTE NOW
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MELENDEZ.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. ON THE ITEM. MISTER
COOPER YOU MAY CLOSE THAT MISTER
SPEAKER.
OLYMPIC MY COLLEAGUES FOR THEIR
CONCERNS AND COMMENTS UNLIKELY
CONSENT AMONG ONE WORK WITH YOU
IN. A COURT FILING WHICH ON IT
IS TOUGH FOR KIDS IN THE BOTTOM
LINE.
KIDS DON'T TELL THE PARENTS A
LOT OF THINGS WE WANT TO HAVE AN
AVENUE FOR THAT CHILD TO GO TO
AND GET MEDICAL HELP IF VIOLENCE
OCCURS AGAINST.
AND JUST LITTLE THINGS WITH KIDS
KIDS ARE FORTHCOMING.
I STILL HAVE AVENUE AVAILABLE
AND PARENTS WILL BE NOTIFIED SO
WITH THAT ARE STIFF YASSER AYE
VOTE.
WITH THAT CLERK LOVE THE ROLE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
A CLERK WILL. CLOSE THE ROLE
TALLY THE VOTE EYES FORTY EIGHT
KNOWS FIFTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WORD FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE TWENTY THREE AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SIX CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
SIX BY SOME A MEMBER STEINORTH
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY TO
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES.
MISTER STEINORTH.
YEAH A GOOD MORNING MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY SIX CREATES A PILOT
PROJECT IN SALMON MEDINA COUNTY
TO ALLOW FOR INJURED LAW
ENFORCEMENT CANINES.
TO BE TRANSPORTED TO A
VETERINARY HOSPITAL USING AN
AMBULANCE.
THANKFULLY THIS IS NOT A COMMON
ISSUE BUT WHEN OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT ANIMALS ARE INJURED
THE CURRENT PRACTICES TO SCOOP
AND RUN THE ANIMAL BY PUTTING
THEM IN THE POLICE CAR.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS ISN'T ADVICE
BECAUSE THE ANIMAL CAGES AND
POLICE CARS ARE TOO CRAMPED FOR
THE ENTERTAINING AND THEIR
HANDLER TO FIT AT THE SAME TIME.
THIS BILL IS SUPPORTED BY A
VARIETY OF PUBLIC SAFETY
ASSOCIATIONS AND THERE IS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
NAME IS STEINORTH SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
CAR CLUB NARAL. ON MEMBERS LOVE.
DESIRED ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY THE VOTE I
SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS MOVING VERY BRIEFLY BACK
TO GUESS INTRODUCTIONS MISTER
LEVINE I BELIEVE YOUR GUESTS
HAVE ARRIVED IN THE CHAMBER.
HOW MUCH MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I GOT FORTY FIVE
STUDENTS FROM CASA GRANDE HIGH
SCHOOL IN PETALUMA JOINING ME
TODAY ALONG WITH THEIR TEACHER
MS LISA KANE PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING THEM?
AND BACK IN FILE ORDER WHERE A
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY FOUR AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY TWO BY MISTER
LEVINE THE CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE THIRTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE AND
ACTUALLY TO HOUSING MISTER
LEVINE YOU MAY OPEN. BIGGER MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS BILL
WILL ALLOW JURISDICTIONS TO WAVE
PERMIT FEES FOR SENIORS THAT
HAVE DISABILITIES TO MAKE THEIR
HOMES SAFER FOR THEM TO LIVE
THERE AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS LEVINE SEEN NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
COR CLUB IN THE ROW ALL MEMBERS
VOTE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
WHO DESIRE TO VOTE?
CLARK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE TALLY
THE VOTE AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES WORD FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY FIVE.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE THE
CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE BY SOME THE
MEMBER CABALLERO AND ACTUALLY TO
THE SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT.
MS CABALLERO.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE IS A
DISTRICT BILL THAT IMMENSE THE
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT ACT.
IT'S THREE COMMON SENSE REFORMS
THAT WILL NUMBER ONE MAKE IT
EASIER FOR LOW INCOME SENIORS TO
GET A PARCEL. TAX EXEMPTION
PROCESSED
NUMBER TWO WOULD HELP TO ENSURE
SOCIO ECONOMIC DIVERSITY ON THE
WATER DISTRICT BOARD. AND THREE
PROTECT COMMUNITY REPRESENTATION
BY PREVENTING AT LARGE VACANCY
APPOINTMENTS
THE BILL IS SUPPORTED BY THIS
SANTA CLARA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT. AND THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
AS WELL AS BY THE LOCAL CHAPTERS
OF THE NAACP AND ASKS ME.
AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY NINE RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THE
ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS CABALLERO. SEEMED
NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM.
CLERK LOCAL OF. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS
VOTE OF THIS OUT OF VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF ON
I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SIX IS AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY THREE.
CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FORTY
THREE BY SOME A MEMBER EGGMAN
AND OTHERS AND ACTUALLY THE
STATE GOVERNMENT.
DOCTOR EGGMAN FEMALE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY
FIVE FORTY THREE IS A BIPARTISAN
DEAL THAT HELPED BRING MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY TO OUR LARGE
STATE PROJECTS. DEALING WITH
INFRASTRUCTURE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
A DOCTOR EGGMAN SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLL-ON
MEMBERS.
BIZARRE ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS HIGHER
THOUGH.
CLARK WELL.
CLOSER ALL TELL YOU THAT I SIXTY
SEVEN AT NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN PASS RETAIN.
WHERE FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
EIGHT?
HR ONE OUT TO THE CAR PARADE
HOUSE RESOLUTION WENT OUT TO BUY
SOME THE MEMBER BURKE RELATIVE
TO TAKE OUR DAUGHTERS AND SONS
TO WORK DAY TWENTY FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY.
MS BURKE YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT TO YOU HOUSE
RESOLUTION ONE HUNDRED AND TWO
HR ONE OF TWO DECLARES APRIL
TWENTY FIFTH AS. TAKE OUR
DAUGHTERS AND SONS TO WORK TING
THE TAKER DOT DAUGHTERS TO WORK
PROGRAM WAS CREATED AS A
RESPONSE TO RESEARCH THAT SHOWED
THAT BY EIGHTH GRADE MANY GIRLS
WERE DROPPING OUT OF SCHOOL HAD
LOW ESTEEM LOW SELF ESTEEM AND
LACKED CONFIDENCE.
THE PROGRAM THAT NAME WAS LATER
CHANGED TO FUNDS IN ORDER TO
REFLECT THE BOYS COULD FACE MANY
OF THE SAME CHALLENGES THE GIRLS
DO.
TODAY THE PROGRAM IS ONE OF THE
LARGEST PUBLIC AWARENESS
CAMPAIGNS OF MORE THAN THIRTY
NINE MILLION PARTICIPANTS
ANNUALLY MORE THAN THREE MILLION
ORGANIZATIONS AND WORKPLACES
PARTICIPATE.
INCLUDING OUR DAUGHTERS AND SONS
TO THE WORKPLACE DOES MORE THAN
JUST EXPOSE THEM TO WHAT PARENTS
ARE MENTORS DO DURING THE DAY IT
SHOWS THEM THE VALUE OF THEIR
EDUCATION HOW TO ACHIEVE LIFE
BALANCE. AND MOST IMPORTANTLY
INSPIRES THEM TO GO ON TO CREATE
A BRIGHTER STRONGER FUTURE FOR
THEIR COMMUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MS BURKE.
SEEM NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION ON
THE RESOLUTION.
MS BURKE YOU WOULD LIKE CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
YES PLEASE.
MS BURKE IS REQUESTING CO AUTHOR
SO THE FIRST ROLE WILL BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLE.
MEMBERS THIS IS CO AUTHORS
COAUTHORS AN HR ONE OF TWO.
CO AUTHORS.
ON THE RESOLUTION.
QUIRK WELL.
CLOSER OTHER SIXTY NINE CO
AUTHORS ADDED WITHOUT OBJECTION
WE MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
HOUSE RESOLUTION ALL THOSE IN
FAVOR SAY AYE.
AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE AYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED
.
MEMBERS IN FILE ORDER WORD FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY NINE EIGHT J.
OUR THIRTY EIGHT.
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION THIRTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MATHIS AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO DANCE AND
RESERVOIRS.
MR MATHIS YOU MAY OPEN. MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT AG OUR
THIRTY EIGHT.
AS YOU'RE ALL AWARE. ON FEBRUARY
SEVENTH.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE ORAL DAM
SPILLWAYS FELLED RESULTING IN
AWARENESS.
OR OUTDATED SAFETY AND
INSPECTION REQUIREMENTS
FOR DAMS UNDER OUR STATE
JURISDICTION.
IN RESPONSE OF THIS WE ADOPTED
A. B..
TWELVE SEVENTY
GALLAGHER.
WHICH STRENGTHENED OUR STATES
DAM SAFETY PROGRAM BY REQUIRING
REGULAR INSPECTION SCHEDULES FOR
DAMS AND RESERVOIRS. SETING.
METICULOUS STANDARDS
FOR THE INSPECTIONS AND
REQUIRING.
THAT OUR EXPERTS BE CONSOLIDATED
TO UPDATE INSPECTION.
AND RE EVALUATION PROTOCOLS.
HOWEVER.
THERE ARE. TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX DAMS THAT DO NOT
FALL.
WITHIN OUR STATE JURISDICTION.
THUS THESE NEWLY IMPLEMENTED
SAFETY REGULATIONS DO NOT APPLY
TO THEM.
OUR STATE HAS BEEN FORTUNATE
ENOUGH NOT TO HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE.
IT IS AFTER IS THE RESULT.
WE DAM ARRESTS OR FAILURE UNDER.
FEDERAL JURISDICTION AND
OVERSIGHT.
HOWEVER THE CHANCES OF SUCH AN
OCCURRENCE TAKING PLACE INCREASE
EACH PASSING YEAR.
OUR EXISTING FLOOD CONTROL
INFRASTRUCTURE IS BECOMING
OUTDATED. AND IN NEED OF
CONSTANT REPAIR.
AS SUCH.
INCREASES IN SAFETY INSPECTIONS
AS WELL AS REEVALUATION
PROTOCOLS MUST.
ALSO FOLLOW SUIT.
THESE DAMS WOULD GREATLY BENEFIT
FROM A YOUR OF OPERATING
STANDARDS.
TO BETTER INCORPORATE BEST
PRACTICES.
WE MUST NOW CALL UPON TRONG
GRITS
TO ALSO IMPLEMENT.
COMPREHENSIVE REFORMS FOR ALL
DAMS AND RESERVOIRS UNDER
FEDERAL JURISDICTION.
WITH THESE REFORMS IN PLACE WE
CAN HELP BETTER PROTECT OUR
RESIDENTS.
FROM FUTURE FLOODS.
INFRASTRUCTURE FAILURES.
MEMBERS I'VE TOWARD ALL THE DAMS
IN MY DISTRICT.
AND I'VE LOOKED AT ON THE ARMY
CORPS IS DOING A GREAT JOB AS WE
FACE ON COMING CHALLENGES WE
MOSS.
REMAIN VIGILANT AND WE MUST CALL
UPON CONGRESS TO FOLLOW SUIT
WITH WHAT WE'VE DONE HERE. I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT MISTER SPEAKER
I'D LIKE THE ROLE OF AN FOR CO
AUTHORS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS MATHIS
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
ON THE RESOLUTION THE AUTHORS
ASKING THE FIRST ROLE BE OPEN
FOR CO AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN
THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS THIS IS FOR
PAUL AUTHORS ON AJ OUR THIRTY
EIGHT.
CO AUTHORS.
COAUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLL THEIR
SIXTY SEVEN CO AUTHORS ADDED
THIS IS AN AGE A ARE WE WILL
TAKE A ROLL CALL VOTE.
CLICK LOVE THE ROLL-ON MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO.
THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WHERE FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE THIRTY.
AB NINETEEN NO ONE BY MR
OBERNOLTE CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN NO ONE BY
SOME A MEMBER OBERNOLTE AND
ACTUALLY TEMPERAMENTAL QUALITY.
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB
NINETEEN OH ONE IT WOULD EXTEND
AN EXISTING SEQUEL EXEMPTION FOR
PROJECTS INVOLVING THE REPAIR
AND MAINTENANCE OF ROADWAY
INFRASTRUCTURE IN CITIES OF LESS
THAN ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW OUR SMALL
CITIES TO MORE EFFICIENTLY USE
THERE'S CAST TAKES SCARCE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS I'D I REQUEST
YOUR SUPPORT ON AB NINETEEN OH
ONE.
DAVIS OBERNOLTE SEEN NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CLERK WILL OVER THE ROLE.
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE IN
THE EYES FIFTY FOUR KNOWS FIVE
THAT MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEMS ONE THIRTY ONE
THROUGH ONE THIRTY THREE PASS
AND RETAIN.
ON THE SENATE THIRD READING FILE
FILE ITEMS ONE THIRTY FOUR ONE
THIRTY FIVE.
AS WELL AS WON THIRTY SEVEN PASS
AND RETAIN WORD FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY SIX.
THAT IS S. C. ARE ONE TWENTY SIX
THE CORPORATE.
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
TWENTY SIX BY SENATOR DODD AND
OTHERS RELATIVE TO THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE NAPA COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE
MS AGUIAR-CURRY YOU MAY OPEN.
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT SCR ONE TWENTY
SIX RECOGNIZING THE FIFTIETH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE NAPA COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE.
FIFTY YEARS AGO THE NAPA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS VOTED
UNANIMOUSLY TO CREATE THE NAPA
VALLEY AGRICULTURAL PRESERVE.
THIS WAS THE FIRST OF ITS KIND
IN THE NATION AND PROMPTED
NUMEROUS LAND USE POLICIES TO
PROTECT NAPA VALLEY FARMLAND.
PRIORITIZING AGRICULTURE AS THE
BEST USE OF THE LAND AND
PROTECTING THE LAND FROM URBAN
SPRAWL.
YEAH PRESERVATIVES CONTINUE TO
PROTECT OVER THIRTY THOUSAND
ACRES OF WORLD'S MOST PROCEED
PRISTINE AND FERTILE
AGRICULTURAL LAND.
THE I. PRESERVE IN BODIES NAPA
COUNTY SPIRIT OF PROMOTING.
INNOVATIVE SUSTAINABILITY
EFFORTS.
THE AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRIES
CHARITABLE LEADERSHIP.
PROGRESSIVE FARM WORKER HOUSING
PROGRAMS.
AND COLLABORATION.
AS A FARMER I KNOW FIRST HAND OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF OUR
AGRICULTURAL LAND.
AND HOW THE LAND HOUSE A
POSITIVE IMPACT ON OUR REGION.
I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SCR
ONE TWENTY SIX TO CELEBRATE AND
HONOR THE FIFTIETH ANNIVERSARY
OF THE NAPA AG PRESERVE. THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MS AGUILAR HURRY.
SEEING KNOW DIVISIONAL
DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM.
MS AGUIAR-CURRY WOULD YOU LIKE
CO AUTHORS ON THE REST OF.
SUCH.
YES I WOULD THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS SAGER CURRY FIRST
ROLE THE FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
S. YOU ARE CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLL-ON.
MEMBERS THIS IS CO AUTHORS.
ADDING ONTO SCR ONE TWENTY SIX.
CO AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION.
S. COAUTHORS CLERK WILL.
CLOSE THE ROLE THERE SIXTY SIX.
COOPER IS ADDED.
WITHOUT OBJECTION I MEAN WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THE
RESOLUTION  THOSE
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
THE EYES HAVE IT THE RESOLUTION
IS ADOPTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT CONSENT
CALENDAR.
IS ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR
.
SEEING HEARING ON THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND DAY CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN SEVENTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND OTHERS AND
EXPLAIN TO FIRE INSURANCE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THEIR ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR MEMBERS THIS IS
CONSENT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE THIS IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
THIS IS CONSENT.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
MEMBERS ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WELL CLOSE THE ROLE ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR SAN
COUNTERS ADOPTED.
THE CLERK WILL READ THE
REMAINING ITEMS ON.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
S. UNABLE SEVENTEEN NINETY NINE.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO SUM ABLE
EIGHTEEN HUNDRED AYE SEVERINO
ZERO A SINGLE TWENTY.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO SINGLE SEVEN
FIVE I SEVENTY KNOWS I AM A
EIGHTEEN OF FIVE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO SINGLE NINETEEN TWENTY FIVE
AYE SEVENTY NOSES LEGAL
NINETEENTH
THE TOO I SEVENTY NO ZERO SINGLE
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. I
SEVENTY KNOWS A LITTLE TOO
THOUSAND I SEVENTY NO ZERO CYCLE
TWENTY FORTY FIVE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO NIELSEN ONE FORTY SIX I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SINGLE TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT. AYE SEVENTY
NO ZERO CYCLE TWENTY SEVENTEEN I
SEVENTY NO ZERO LABEL TWENTY
EIGHTY ONE I SEVENTY NO ZERO SAY
BETWEEN THREE NINETY SEVEN. I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SINGLE TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY TWO I SEVENTY NO ZERO
CYCLE TIME FOR SIXTY NINE I
SEVENTY NO ZERO SINGLE TWENTY
FOUR NINETY.
I SEVENTY NO SURVIVAL TWENTY
FIVE SIXTEEN I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SAN MOSTLY BY THIRTY TWO I
SEVENTY NO ZERO MIL TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY FOUR I SEVENTY NO ZERO
SINGLE TWENTY SIX FORTY SIX WITH
URGENCY.
I SEMI NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY AS
SEMI KNOWS HERE ON THE BILL.
SOME OUTSIDE SEVEN FORTY FIVE
AYE SEVENTY NO ZERO SIMILAR
TWENTY ONE I SEVENTY NO ZERO A
SINGLE TWENTY TRAINS YOU I
SEVENTY NO ZERO XML TWENTY
THIRTY EIGHT AYE SEMI NO ZERO
SYMBOL TIENE SEVENTEEN. AYE
SEVERINO ZERO SUM ABLE TWENTY
NINE NINETY
I SIMPLY KNOW ZERO ASYLUM THIRTY
FORTY THREE I SEVENTY NO ZERO A
SIMILAR THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE
GUYS SEVENTY NO ZERO. SUM OF
THIRTY FORTY FIVE AYE SEMI NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT LUCIEN
ONE SEVENTY THREE.
I SEVEN OH ZERO ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION TO IT TOO
I SEVEN KNOW ZERO SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION WENT AWAY.
I SEVEN HOSER AND SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
EIGHTEEN.
I SEVENTY NO ZERO.
MEMBERS COUPLE OF BRIEF
ANNOUNCEMENTS.
THE FOLLOWING COMMITTEES WILL BE
MEETING UPON ADJOURNMENT.
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION GEO
WILL BE MEETING IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OH TWO.
AND JOBS ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND THE ECONOMY WILL BE MEETING
UPON ADJOURNMENT IN ROOM ONE.
SEVEN THAT'S GEO AND FORTY TWO A
TWO.
JOBS COMMITTEE IN ONE TWENTY
SEVEN UPON ADJOURNMENT.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY APRIL TWENTY SEVENTH KNOW
FLOOR SESSION NO CHECK IN
SESSION.
MONDAY APRIL THIRTIETH FLOOR
SESSION. IS AT ONE PM.
IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION THE
QUORUM CALL THIS LIFTED.
AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED.
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY.
WE ARE AND ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT ADJOURNMENTS
IN MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR CALL
STATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR OF THE
BILLY
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR.
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK.
ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
WILL BEGIN WITH MISTER LACKEY.
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS.
I RISE TO ADJOURN A MEMORY OF
RONALD LEADER ME.
HE WAS A CONSTITUENT OF MINE
BEST KNOWN FOR HIS ROLES THE
UNFORGIVING DRILL INSTRUCTOR AND
FULL METAL JACKET.
MISTER ME WAS BORN IN KANSAS IN
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR.
UPON GRADUATING HIGH SCHOOL HE
ANSWERED THE CALL OF DUTY AND
SERVED AS A MARINE DURING THE
VIETNAM WAR.
HE SELFLESSLY DEFENDED OUR
COUNTRY FOR ELEVEN YEARS BEFORE
ROCKET ATTACK.
LEFT WITH SHRAPNEL LOGIC WAS
BACK.
ANDTHAT ENDED HIS MILITARY
SERVICE.
HIS EXPERIENCE IN THE MARINES
ESPECIALLY AS A DRILL
INSTRUCTOR.
SHAPED MANY OF HIS ACTING ROLES.
MISTER ME WAS NOT ONE TO SHY
AWAY FROM PORTRAYING AN
AGGRESSIVE.
EVEN OBSCENE MILITANT CHARACTER.
HIS ROLE AS A SERGEANT AT
SERGEANT HARTMAN.
HE REMINDS RECRUITS.
BECAUSE I'M HARD.
YOU WILL NOT LIKE ME.
BUT THE MORE YOU HATE ME THE
MORE YOU WILL LEARN.
I'M HARD BUT I'M FAIR.
THIS IS A MESSAGE WE CAN ALL
KEEP IN OUR MINDS.
HIS CLEVER LIVELY PERSONA WILL
BE GREATLY MISSED.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE HIS
BROTHERS.
CHILDREN HIS GRANDCHILDREN AND
HIS GREAT GRANDCHILDREN.
I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME.
IN THE JOURNEY AND RON ONLY
ARMIES MEMORY TODAY.
A PASSING ALONG CONDOLENCES TO
HIS FAMILY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER LACKEY.
IS CARILLO YOUR RECOGNIZE.
MEMBERS.
TODAY I WOULD LIKE TO ADJOURN IN
THE MEMORY OF MY BELOVED
GRANDMOTHER.
HE SEVEN DON'T KNOW THAT NOBODY
GETS
PAST MARCH TWENTY SEVEN.
AT THE AGE OF EIGHTY FOUR.
HER LAST YEAR BROUGHT SUIT
BROUGHT TO HER AND OUR FAMILY A
LOT OF PAIN UNEXPECTED BATTLES.
WITH DEMENTIA AND OTHER HEALTH
ISSUES.
OUR TIME WITH OUR FAMILY IS
PRECIOUS
AND SEEKING PUBLIC OFFICE CAN
TAKE US AWAY FROM OUR LOVED
ONES.
WE ALL WISH WE HAD MORE TIME.
TIME BEING THE MOST PRECIOUS
GIFT YOU CAN EVER GIVE OR
RECEIVE.
I AM HERE.
BECAUSE OF HER STRENGTH AND
LOVE.
I KNOW THAT SHE IS PROUD OF ME.
SHE LOVED TO LAUGH BEEN DANCE.
AND I'VE INHERITED HER LOVE OF
MUSIC SHE WOULD ALWAYS. HOME A
TUNE WHENEVER WE WOULD TAKE A
STROLLER WHEN SHE WOULD STEER
HER COFFEE.
I DO THE SAME.
SHE HELPED RAISE ME AND SHE
POURED HER LOVE AND TO ME.
SHE WAS A NURSE IN OUR HOME
COUNTRY.
HOW MANY WOUNDED PEOPLE DURING
THE CIVIL WAR IN EL SALVADOR?
SHE OFTEN TOLD STORY.
ABOUT HER CHILDHOOD.
AND RUNNING AROUND IN OPEN
FIELDS.
BEFORE CHAOS DESTROYED A COUNTRY
THAT SHE LOVED.
SHE EMIGRATED TO THE US WITH ME
WHEN I WAS ONLY FIVE YEARS OLD.
CROSSING BORDERS.
STARTING A NEW LIFE WAS
UNDOCUMENTED WOMAN THE WOMAN OF
COLOR.
YET SHE PERSISTED.
SHE BECAME A RESIDENT.
SHE BECAME A HOME CARE WORKER
CARING FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
ALL WHILE LEARNING A NEW
LANGUAGE IN HER OWN WAY.
SHE LAUGHED OFTEN SHE TOLD
STORIES HE LOVE THE WATER.
TRAVELING EATING OUT SHOPPING.
WEARING HER FINEST JEWELERY.
THE RING THAT I WEAR NOW.
WITH HERS.
SHE LOVES CELEBRATING BIRTHDAYS
SHE LOVED LIFE.
CALIFORNIA IS A BETTER PLACE
BECAUSE SHE WAS A PART OF IT.
I MISS HER MORE THAN I COULD
EVER POSSIBLY SHARE.
BUT I NO THAT SHE WILL BE
FOREVER WITH ME.
MAY SHE REST IN PEACE.
MUCH TO LEAD THEM.
WE WILL BE OKAY.
YOU DID A REALLY GOOD JOB
.
AND MS FRIEDMAN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER OUT AND
ONE WAS A PILLAR OF THE LOCKING
OUT A COMMUNITY AND A REMARKABLE
PHILANTHROPIST TO TOUCH THE
LIVES OF COUNTLESS CALIFORNIANS.
BORN IN SALT LAKE CITY UTAH HE
MARRIED HIS WIFE KATHY IN
NINETEEN SIXTY AND LAUNCHED A
CAREER IN THE TRUCKING INDUSTRY
EVENTUALLY SETTLING IN GLENDALE.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX HE
FOUNDED THE ALLEN ONE COMPANY A
TRUCK BROKERAGE FIRM THAT BROUGH
TO OFFICES IN THIRTY FOUR CITIES
WITH FOUR HUNDRED AND FIFTY
EMPLOYEES.
AS AS BUSINESS EXPANDED ALLEN
BECAME A LEADER IN THE
TRANSPORTATION INDUSTRY
RECOGNIZED BY HIS PEERS AND
COMMUNITY WITH MULTIPLE AWARDS.
HOWEVER ALLEN IS PROBABLY BEST
KNOWN FOR HIS UNDER STATED
DIRECT GENEROSITY GUIDED BY HIS
STRONG CATHOLIC FAITH.
AMONG MANY POSITIONS HE SERVED
AS THE CHAIRMAN OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AT SAINT FRANCIS HIGH
SCHOOL THE PRESIDENT OF THE
BOARD OF REGENTS AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF PORTLAND. AND A
TRUSTEE ON THE BOARD FOR THE
CATHOLIC EDUCATION FOUNDATION OF
THE ARTS DYESS OF LOS ANGELES.
HE ESTABLISHED THE LAND FAMILY
SCHOLARSHIP TO BENEFIT STUDENTS
FROM SAINT FRANCIS HIGH SCHOOL.
AND HELPED LAUNCH THE ANNUAL LOS
ANGELES CATHOLIC PRAYER BRADFORD
BREAKFAST IN TWO THOUSAND FIVE.
AN EVENT THAT HAS GROWN INTO THE
LARGEST CATHOLIC PRAYER
BREAKFAST IN THE NATION.
WITH ALL OF HIS ACCOMPLISHMENTS
ALEC CONSIDERED HIS ROLE AS THE
FAMILY PATRIARCH TO BE HIS
GREATEST.
TO ALLEN AND ALL THOSE WHO KNEW
HIM HIS LIFE WAS WONDERFUL BY
ANY MEASURE.
TODAY I ASK THAT WE ADJOURN THE
MEMORY OF THIS WONDERFUL MAN AND
SEND OUR HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES
TO CATHY HIS WIFE OF FIFTY SEVEN
YEARS THEIR SIX CHILDREN. TWENTY
TWO GRANDCHILDREN AND TWO GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN AS WELL AS HIS
SISTERS KATIE AND JUDY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS FRIEDMAN.
MISTER SANTIAGO
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
SURROUNDED BY HER FRIENDS.
FAMILY.
ALICE FLEET IF LEASE.
HANDELMAN PASSED AWAY SUNDAY.
APRIL FIRST
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN.
THIS HAPPENS BE THE FIRST TIME.
I DO AND I JOIN IN MEMORY.
AND.
DECIDED TO DO FOR THIS ONE
BECAUSE THE IMPACT.
THAT YOU HAD UNDER SURROUNDING
COMMUNITIES.
NOT ONLY THE LOS ANGELES AREA.
BUT ALL AROUND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
SHE WAS BORN IN GREAT NECK NEW
YORK.
ON MAY FIRST AND SETTLED IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT.
SHE MET AND MARRIED THE LOVE OF
HER LIFE.
A PERSON MOST PEOPLE KNOW IN LOS
ANGELES.
I RUN HANDLE.
THE TWO HAD CHILDREN.
BY THE NAME OF ARIEL SAM.
AND SAM.
IT'S BROUGHT THEM PRIDE AND JOY.
SHE EARNED A DEGREE IN EARLY
CHILDHOOD DEVELOPMENT.
AND HER ENTIRE LIFE WAS
DEDICATED TO CHILDREN IN FACT
SHE WAS A CARD A KINDERGARTEN
TEACHER.
ALICE WAS PASSIONATE.
SHE PURSUED AN ACCEPTANCE OF
PEOPLE AND PARTICULARLY DEDICATE
HER LIFE.
THOSE CHILDREN WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS.
SHE WAS INVOLVED IN HELPING
MOTHERS AND CHILDREN.
WHO NEEDED THEIR SUPPORT?
AT AGE EIGHTEEN SHE WAS
DIAGNOSED WITH MULTIPLE
SCLEROSIS.
BUT THAT IN STOPPER SHE BECAME
AN ACTIVIST.
USING HER KINDERGARTEN TEACHING
EXPERIENCE.
LATER SHE CREATED.
METHODS TO OPEN UP IN SHAPE
MINES.
SHE INTRODUCED THE KIDS ON THE
BLOCK PROGRAM.
THE LOS ANGELES JEWISH DAY
SCHOOLS.
WHICH PRESENTED STORIES AND
SITUATIONS AND GAVE LIFE SIZE
PROJECTS.
AND PUPPETS.
FOR CHILDREN WITH VARYING
DISABILITIES.
WE WILL REMEMBER.
AND THE MANY CHILDREN'S AND
FAMILY'S.
ACROSS OUR PATH.
WILL REMEMBER.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO.
MS CAMARGO DOVE. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF MISS GLORIA ALL THIS
WHO PASSED AWAY ON APRIL
THIRTEENTH TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN.
MISS ALICE WAS A RESIDENT OF THE
FIFTY FOURTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
AND PLAYED AN ACTIVE ROLE WITH
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
DEMOCRATIC PARTY. AS BOTH A
DELEGATE AND AN EMPLOYEE.
MISS OUT OF US WAS BORN AND
RAISED IN THE BRONX.
NEW YORK.
LATER SHE MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
WHERE SHE WORKED FOR THE BANK OF
AMERICA FOR VERY MANY YEARS.
IN NINETEEN NINETY SIX SHE WAS
HIRED BY GARY SHEA FORMER LA
DEMOCRATIC PARTY CHAIR.
AND CONTINUED ON TO SERVE THREE
CHAIRS FOR A TOTAL OF TWENTY TWO
YEARS OF SERVICE TO THE PARTY.
HER DEDICATION TO THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY DID NOT STOP IN
CALIFORNIA.
IN FACT A CONTINUED ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY. FROM CHICAGO TO NEW
YORK TO WASHINGTON DC.
WHERE SHE TRAVEL TO SUPPORT
DEMOCRATIC ISSUES AND CANDIDATES
SHE BELIEVED AND?
GLORIAHAD A HEART OF GOLD.
AND WAS A PERSON WHO NO ONE
SHE ONCE FLEW ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TO HOLD A VIGIL FOR THE LATE
LUTHER VANDROSS.
AND FLEW ACROSS THE WORLD TO
SOUTH AFRICA TO HONOR NELSON
MANDELA.
IT WAS IN HER NATURE TO SHOW
RESPECT AND DEFERENCE TO PEOPLE
WHO MADE THE WORLD A BETTER
PLACE.
MISS ALICE WAS A DEVOUT CATHOLIC
AND WORSHIP AT SAINT BERNADETTE
CATHOLIC CHURCH IN BALDWIN
HILLS.
ALSO IN THE FIFTY FOURTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
WHEN THE POPE MADE A VISIT TO
PHILADELPHIA AND TWENTY FIFTEEN.
MS ALVEZ DROPPED EVERYTHING AND
JOIN THE CROWDS TO WELCOME HIM.
SHE WILL BE MOURNED AND MISSED
BY HER FAMILY AND ALL WHO KNEW
HER.
PLEASE JOIN ME TODAY AND
ADJOURNING IN THE MEMORY OF MISS
GLORIA ALVIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE BRING
THE NAMES OF THE DESTINY PRINTED
IN THE JOURNAL ALL REQUESTS
RICHARD A MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WILL
BE PASSED RETAIN ALL MOTION
SHALL WE CONTINUE.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FURTHER
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER
GRAYSON MOOS.
AND MR BONTA SECONDS THAT THIS
HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL
MONDAY.
APRIL THIRTIETH. AT ONE PM
.
I DON'T KNOW.
VOTE CHANGE GRAYSON. AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY NINE.
FROM I TO NOT VOTING.
VOTE CHANGE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AS ONLY
WELL TWENTY FOUR THIRTY NINE.
I TO NOT VOTING